Oki no Shonen From today onwards, you
are a member of the Armed Detective Agency. You may have
heard
of an armed detective.
Group I'll teach you one thing about living in this town If you
ever meet this guy,
run away
They're called the Port Mafia, they
're the most dangerous people in this city's black society
Fear this spec for the population
There's a bounty on the black market The
amount of the bounty is 76
If he's caught, the
boat mafia will receive it I'll
crush the plan of the former port mafia Dazai no Mikoto You will stop my plan You're kidding,
murder  As an assassin of the Port Mafia, I
don't want to kill any more.
People who make people
say that they can't live without someone telling them that they can live  There is no way
out other
than fighting.
We are the last ones left. I will definitely get that town. To the
sinners, God's grace.  If you
tear this head off, a
curse will be activated on about 20% of the people in the town.
Yokohama Incineration
Operation
We are looking for a certain book.
is the strongest in Yokohama and
wants to protect this city Who the hell are the beacons
of the counterattack?  It's
just coming like Stray Dogs
Ah,
anyway, you should be on the side of saving people It's
somewhat nicer
Something's happening The
psychic will wake up
forever Date's sleep It's your way to play with your
poor head  The
poison I have is the younger sister of cannibalism.
It's a virus-type supernatural power possessed by criminals. If
one of them dies, the
supernatural power stops.
I'll read through everything
from my life Of course, of course, the
true nature of the book is a novel A blank
literary award that turns out to be true I will use that book to
create a world without sins and abilities
Humans are  Everyone is
sinful and
stupid.In
your organization, rats
can't eat away at you.Let's
prove it and show it.Let's get rid of it.Let's
become stronger.To
deny Akutagawa's strength,
what are you toasting to
?  To Dog
[music]